à vous de venez effectivement l'une des
rares femmes réalisatrices de films X
reconnu quels ont été à ce moment-là les
réactions de votre entourage à commencer
par vos parents
ouf
ovidi bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde a parlé
alors vous êtes né le 25 août 1980 à
Lille sous le prénom de Héloïse alors
vos parents sont cadres dans la fonction
publique vous placez votre
pré-adolescence à Bordeaux ensuite
Châteauroux et Tours
vétérinaire oui oui vous avez un immense
amour des animaux ce qui fait qu'en 93 à
l'âge de 13 ans vous faites déjà une
année entière sans manger de viande oui
et je suis devenue une définitivement
végétarienne en 94 à l'âge de de 14 ans
ça fait
17 ans de que je suis végétarienne et je
suis encore là en bonne santé
alors première relation sexuelle avec
une fille à l'âge de 14 ans et ensuite
un garçon à l'âge de 14 ans également
c'est ça je sais que ça peut paraître
particulièrement jeune mais j'étais
assez je dirais assez mûr pour mon âge
et à l'âge de 17 ans ensuite voilà j'ai
commencé à vivre sans mes parents donc
c'est une période mon adolescent j'étais
quand même assez
vous créez un scalp alors un scalp c'est
une section carrément anti Le Pen avec
votre petit ami donc déjà très militante
politique à cette époque là en tout cas
ça m'a permis de m'intéresser à
certaines lectures auxquelles les autres
jeunes gens de mon âge ne
s'intéressaient pas et ça m'a permis de
me cultiver au moins ça m'a permis de
développer un certain esprit critique et
bon j'y repense avec avec le sourire on
va dire alors à l'époque vous habillez
en pancakes avec des jupes courtes des
gros ranger et vous fréquentez des
féministes intégristes vous dites des
nanas à sweat-shirt capuche pour qu'il
la levrette c'est la soumission oui
c'était une version du féminisme qui
était très caricatural effectivement et
qui était très peu ouverte sur la
question sexuelle et je trouvais ça
relativement ennuyeux et
contre-productif alors c'est à saison
que vous louez votre première cassette
porno ensuite il y en aura des centaines
jusqu'à votre rupture avec les
féministes intégristes c'est ça en fait
à partir de 16 ans j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser à ce qui était la
pornographie puisque je faisais partie
du groupe qui critiquait la pornographie
donc je me suis dit autant savoir de
quoi de quoi il est question et de quoi
je parle et je me suis rendu compte que
la plupart des films que je jouais ne
correspondaient pas forcément avec
précision au discours qu'on pouvait
tenir alors en voyant les pornostars
américaines vous dites je veux faire ça
quoi
oui oui effectivement à 18 ans je me
suis dit je vais franchir le câble je
vais faire ça je pense que c'était par
esprit de provocation parce que c'était
probablement le pire métier socialement
parlant que je pouvais faire à l'époque
et pour moi il y avait rien de plus
logique j'étais punk bon bah j'allais
devenir porno star voilà j'allais
devenir c'était une certaine marginalité
à l'histoire
de philosophie et lorsque vous décidez
d'entrer dans le milieu de la
pornographie vous êtes à l'université
vous vous rendez au salon haute-video à
Paris pour rencontrer les collaborateurs
de la boîte la plus sérieuse à votre à
votre avis Marc Dorcel c'est ça
exactement parce que je j'avais quand
même une vision très professionnelle de
la chose et je commençais déjà à
réfléchir à une à la réalisation tout
simplement j'avais ça quand même en
ligne de mire et pour moi il était
évident que j'allais pas passer par la
case à mat puisque en fait le la
sexualité était quelque chose
[Musique]
du scénario non mon Dieu
c'était dans une fête foraine et je
crois que j'étais une demoiselle
d'honneur voilà encore encore un film
que je n'ai pas pu montrer mes parents
alors là vous avez votre première fiche
de paye quoi vous êtes une travailleuse
du sexe tout à fait alors vous n'avez
pas 20 ans lorsque vous devenez
également réalisatrice avec votre
premier long métrage un film érotique au
fantastique qui s'appelle orgie en noir
et c'est quoi l'histoire ça se passe
dans un cimetière c'est une reine des
morts avec des zombies et oui
effectivement ça faisait à peine un an
un an et demi peut-être que j'étais que
j'étais devenue que j'étais actrice et
je j'ai commencé la réalisation en fait
quasiment instantanément voilà vous
devenez la plus jeune réalisatrice de
films pornographiques de toute
l'histoire du cinéma c'est vrai
horrifique
qui est votre deuxième long métrage
c'était quoi l'histoire
d'une femme insatisfaite en fait à
partir de Lilith c'est là où j'ai
vraiment commencé à travailler le
concept de pornographie à destination
des femmes c'est vraiment à partir de ce
moment là que je me suis affirmée en
tant que réalisatrice et que et voilà
j'ai travaillé dans sur ce concept là
alors
la profession vous devenez effectivement
l'une des rares femmes réalisatrices de
films X reconnu qu'elles ont été à ce
moment-là les réactions de votre
entourage à commencer par vos parents
ouf mes parents évidemment n'ont
absolument pas ça la Champagne parce que
pour eux c'était une condamnation il
savait que j'allais être marqué au fer
rouge toute ma vie il partait du
principe que leur fille pouvait avoir
d'autres capacités c'est normal en tant
que parents et que j'avais probablement
rater mes études rater ma vie et que
professionnellement j'allais être cramé
ad vitam éternam ce en quoi il n'avait
pas tout à fait tort mais il n'avait pas
de non plus tout à fait raison puisque
l'avenir a prouvé le contraire et après
ils ont compris en fait que vous aviez
fait ce choix en faisant complètement
abstraction de la pression sociale
ils ont fini par par le comprendre ils
ont fini par comprendre qu'elles étaient
mes revendications aussi ils ont compris
qu'il y avait une démarche réfléchie
derrière et que surtout j'étais pas dans
une autodestruction il voyait bien qu'au
quotidien à cette époque là ben je
j'avais une vie relativement rangée ce
qui est toujours le cas je prenais pas
de drogue j'étais toujours végétarienne
je sortais pas enfin il a même une vie
relativement chiante j'ai une vie
relativement chiante faut le dire donc
ils ont été quand même très rassurés les
parents aiment bien que leurs enfants et
des vies un petit peu rangés chiantes
ouais
alors dès vos premiers films les médias
s'intéressent beaucoup à vous vous
devenez un peu l'intello du porno ça a
été votre votre slogan une certaine
façon ça a été mon titre et Macron c'est
c'est vrai que c'est un nom qui est
revenu souvent on m'a taxé de d'intello
ce qui a été bien et pas bien ce qui a
été compliqué c'est que le fait de me
taxer d'un telo venait décrédibiliser
les autres de la profession parce que si
moi j'étais intello ça voulait dire que
les autres étaient crétins et c'est un
titre qui a aussi énormément énervé
parce que beaucoup de gens sont partis
du principe que je ne pouvais pas avoir
droit à cette appellation et pourtant je
n'avais pas revendiqué
à l'époque ça commence par Mireille
Dumas vous faites de la rue Emmanuel
Chain Courbet Ardisson
[Musique]
vous avez de bonnes relations avec les
médias d'une façon généralement
j'avais une relation très très ambigu
puisque je n'avais pas la télé donc en
général quand j'arrivais dans une
émission télé je ne la connaissais pas
et j'y allais vraiment dans un but
presque de propagande finalement je me
disais avant je distribuais des tracts
qui étaient adressés à peine sans
personne maintenant je passe à la
télévision je peux m'adresser à des
centaines de milliers voire des millions
de personnes à la fois et faire passer
mon message et ce qui a été à double
tranchant c'est à dire d'un côté
effectivement ça a pu faire passer des
idées et le concept de pornographie
féminine a pu se propager et existe
aujourd'hui et de plus en plus
mais ça a été assez négative aussi dans
dans le sens où on ne contrôle pas la
diffusion de son image et ça dans quand
j'étais jeune j'en avais pas conscience
qu'à partir du moment on donnait son
image on en était complètement
dépossédés quand on est jeune on a
l'impression qu'on est plus fort que le
monde entier on se dit je contrôle mon
image je vais tous les en gros
c'était ça et en fait non c'est
absolument absurde on fait partie du
spectacle
sur le coup j'ai trouvé ça très
presque plaisant parce que il y a
quelque chose quand même d'assez
flatteur quand on a 18 ans 19 ans se
retrouver tout à coup connu avec des
gens qui nous arrêtent sans arrêt dans
la rue même si on est connu pour de
mauvaises raisons on trouve ça très
drôle je dirais même encore plus quand
c'est pour de mauvaises raisons parce
qu'on a envie de provoquer et après par
la suite là où j'ai commencé à prendre
conscience vraiment de la pression
sociale de tout ce que ça impliqué
j'ai un peu révisé ma copie on va dire
même si je l'assume pleinement mais j'ai
préféré à ce moment-là me faire plus
discrète dans les médias et n'apparaître
qu'à des moments clés quand par exemple
il y avait une sortie de livre des
choses comme ça
à cette époque très peu avant très peu
parce que je tournais peu il faut il
faut savoir que j'étais relativement
pénible aussi j'avais énormément de
conditions et par conséquent je tournais
peu puis j'avais pas envie vraiment de
comprendre alors que moi je devais
tourner une une journée par mois j'ai
gagné très peu d'argent avec ça
et avec la réalisation
moins que si j'avais réalisé
des documentaires ou des choses comme ça
parce que c'est ce sont des films qui
sont relativement peu payés et où les
diffuseurs donnent peu d'argent enfin on
gagne moins d'argent je pense avec un
film pornographique avec un documentaire
animalier par exemple alors sur le plan
amoureux vous êtes marié à l'âge de 18
ans avec un docteur en philosophie qui
avait 10 ans de plus que vous qui
ensuite est devenu collaborateur de
haute vidéo vous êtes resté avec lui
depuis je me suis mariée jeune et j'ai
divorcé jeune et j'avoue
ne pas avoir depuis spécialement de
contact je lui souhaite le meilleur mais
je n'ai ça fait des années que je n'ai
pas une nouvelle et après vous avez eu
plein d'aventures
non je j'ai rencontré une personne après
mon divorce bon je suis tombée très
amoureuse et avec lui avec qui j'ai eu
un enfant
très rangé en fait j'ai une vie ah non
mais quand je dis que j'ai une vie
chiante
on en est on en est à 3 mecs mais oui
j'ai pratiquement été soit en couple
soit
seul je vis seul depuis deux ans mais je
suis pas je suis pas une collectionneuse
moi en fait du tout le meilleur moment
de toute cette époque ça a été quoi
le moment de la réalisation de Lilith
parce que pour moi ça a été le début de
d'un espoir l'espoir de voir que j'avais
un avenir en termes de réalisation et
qui avait quelque chose à travailler
dans cette voie c'est à dire c'était un
film qui était absolument pas abouti ni
quoi que ce soit c'était un essai de
jeunesse finalement ça correspond
à mes débuts aussi au niveau de
l'écriture et pour moi c'était c'était
prometteur voilà le pire moment c'était
quoi
à partir du moment où j'ai commencé à
prendre conscience que il fallait que je
fasse attention à ma sécurité dans la
rue par exemple ça ça a été les premiers
moments où
j'ai où je me suis rendu compte je pense
que je n'avais pas conscience à quel
point le fait de d'être une femme à une
sexualité un peu affichée était aussi
dangereux en fait naïvement je pensais
que les gens allaient juste me traiter
de catin et voilà et basta et je ne
pensais pas que ça pouvait aller jusqu'à
des agressions
verbales et physique je pensais pas que
ça allait jusque là je pensais pas je
pense que je n'avais même pas conscience
du côté positif de la chose c'est à dire
du même des fantasmes que je pouvais
susciter chez les gens je me projetais
pas du tout là-dedans je en fait je suis
pas très je suis pas très sexuelle comme
gonzesse en fin de compte quand on
réfléchisse c'est ça le scoop c'est que
je suis pas très sexuel et je n'avais
pas du tout conscience que je faisais
fantasmer les gens et à partir du moment
où j'en ai vraiment pris conscience ça a
été un petit peu ça m'a inquiété
aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique de
cette époque
non mais je suis pas le genre
nostalgique moi non non vous avez de la
rancune contre quelqu'un non j'ai pas
j'ai pas de rancune j'ai pas de rancune
on m'a fait des tas de tas d'emmerdes ça
c'est sûr m'a mis des tas de bâtons dans
les rouges je pense du fait que j'étais
une femme entre autres mais
non je m'encombre pas de la rancune
aujourd'hui si c'était à refaire votre
vie qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je me pose pas les questions en
ces termes en général je ne regrette pas
ce que j'ai fait parfois je regrette ce
que je n'ai pas fait ce que je n'ai pas
fait c'est
par exemple cultiver un réseau voilà moi
j'ai jamais été mondaine je suis jamais
sorti je suis pas très sociable enfin ça
je le regrette et je regrette aussi de
peut-être de ne pas mettre expatriés à
une époque où j'en avais l'occasion dans
un pays qui m'est cher qui est le
Danemark voilà
c'est mon grand regret aujourd'hui c'est
de ne pas vivre à Copenhague le jour
vous allez mourir
elle exécrée les tiède
par exemple elle faisait une très bonne
quiche sans pâte ça c'est anecdotique
merci c'est très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur vos vidéos merci et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu